I think that the people who have been
doing political satire or the people
I've talked to have really felt like it
used to be the,
again,
the media was the watchdog for um,
those,
you know,
the government and corporate America and
when the media sort of felt like it was
in bed and they were lazy or in bed
with,
with their,
you know,
advertisers.
Um,
I think comics naturally started filling
the role of sort of being the watchdog
of the watchdog,
you know,
pill,
political satire and comedy.
We just started asking the questions
that journalists weren't asking anymore,
uh,
through humor,
through sort of hopefully funny,
righteous sanger,
um,
but also just asking questions that our
audience wanted to hear.
And so we were doing basically a service
we just kept doing,
we were doing,
but then it just transitioned into like,
find out what's going on or if we're
just going to be lied to from right left
and center to provide a haven where at
least people can come together and not
feel crazy.
I feel like,
Hey,
I'm in a group of people who have
understand that everybody's spinning us
and somebody onstage pointing that out
through humor.
At least I can breathe a sigh that I'm
not insane.
When I hear the cacophony of lies,
I think comedy can be a tool for social
activism.
I think that when you point out
hypocrisy again,
because the media often doesn't,
you know,
the,
the followup question should just be put
in the Smithsonian as a relic of media
because there are no follow ups anymore.
People don't have enough historical
knowledge to say,
wait,
you're lying if you don't have enough
knowledge on the environment to say,
uh,
wait.
Scientists say there's global warming,
it's real.
So a lot of information just sort of
floats out there like,
like a thick muggy day and nobody weeds
through it and cuts through the muck and
says,
here's the truth.
And I think that pointing that out
through humor can be a tool to have
people say,
wow,
um,
I should be asking questions and I'm
laughing.
Uh,
and I think that's what's fun,
is that you can ask questions yourself
on stage through humor,
and then that means the audience kind of
scratches a tent and says,
you're right.
And as you watch,
uh,
videos on the web and the daily show,
Colbert,
Bill Maher,
you will see them lay out a case and
make it funny through video,
through things that are out there.
Somebody says one thing one day and
something else the next day.
And,
um,
you know,
we have this amazing medium with which
we can put it out,
right?
[inaudible].